one million deaths a grim milestone for
a pandemic that's not even a year old
in 10 months more people have died from
covet 19 than from
hiv malaria the flu and cholera
combined a hefty body count for a
microscopic pathogen
and some experts think it's an
undercount
the pandemic isn't done yet cases are
spiking in india and europe
complacency and frustration are growing
people had a fear of the coronavirus in
march and april
but they don't anymore some are also
leaving their homes because they have to
go to work
they don't have any money and they don't
have any other options
as the numbers continue to rise how long
before the next
milestone
this is dw's coveted 19 special hello
and welcome to the show i'm steven
beardsley in berlin
1 million deaths in 10 months what began
as a mysterious respiratory disease in
wuhan china
has now spread around the world leaving
a significant body count in its wake
and showing little sign of abating in
the near future here's a look
at how we reach this point
the first death outside of china was
reported in the philippines
on february 2nd just 12 days later
france confirmed the first victim in
europe
at the end of february the united states
reported its first death
on june 28 the global death toll hit
half a million
and just three months later the
millionth victim was confirmed
the u.s has the highest death toll so
far
it also has the highest number of cases
followed by
india and brazil spain has the most
confirmed infections in the european
union
with cases surging across the world
experts expect the global death toll
to climb rapidly in the coming months
[Music]
now one of the country's worst hit by
the pandemic wasn't on that last list
peru which has topped 800 000 infections
has had one of the world's highest
mortality rates and its economy has
shrunk by a whopping 30 percent
but new cases are slowing and that's
prompted the government to begin easing
restrictions
many fear that they're acting too soon
finally able to be by her husband's side
this desert cemetery in northern peru is
the final resting place for local
coronavirus victims
now that restrictions have been eased
relatives are allowed in to visit
even though it isn't at the spot anna
maria and her husband had planned for
me when i went to town to make burial
arrangements
they told me i couldn't bury him in the
plot we had chosen
i was told that an order had been issued
that everyone who died from kovid
had to be buried in this cemetery
others are still fighting for their
lives peru's president says the
country's health care system is stronger
now
than it was at the beginning of the
pandemic
and the government is expanding testing
including in low-income areas of the
capital lima
so with the rate of new infections on
the decline
the government is pushing ahead with
plans to reopen more of the economy
and even start letting in international
flights starting with neighboring
countries
but some health experts are warning
against reopening too fast
reopening gyms bars discos and
other forms of entertainment will be
terrible
so yes it could bring about a second
wave quicker
i think we definitely need to reconsider
these steps
the fear is that peru could repeat the
pattern of other countries
seeing a rise in cases followed by a new
wave
of mass burials
i'm joined now by alan lopez he's an
epidemiologist and professor at the
university of melbourne
which is where he joins me from
professor it's good to have you on the
show
you've said that this death count could
actually be a vast undercount
by how much
well it's hard to say but it's probably
likely to be somewhere between 30 and 60
percent of an undercount due to a number
of factors
why is that what are those factors
well there's four principal factors
stephen that i think are driving the
numbers down one is that doctors are
still learning how to apply the who
rules to certify
uh covert deaths and this they're
getting used to that until they get used
to it properly they'll be under counting
deaths
secondly covert 19
kills people in ways that we're still
learning about in other words that they
magnifies up the background risks if
you've got hypertension
you're a smoker if you're overweight if
you've got chronic lung disease
then it's likely that covert 19 is going
to be more serious for you
and will kill many of the people with
those conditions those co-morbidities
thirdly uh covert 19 is having a big
impact on health services
so in developing poor countries we're
seeing
programs essential programs like hiv
control tv
malaria are all being affected and so
many of the people who need those
services are not getting them
and are probably dying as a result and
even in rich countries
we see people not turning up for cancer
screening when they should be
and finally and perhaps most importantly
many many deaths in the world go
uncounted about
one-third of deaths go unregistered each
year
and even many of those that are
registered don't get a proper
correct cause of death so it's likely
that covert 19 suffers from all those
conditions as well
you mentioned there the comorbidities
can we say if there's a profile to the
average coronavirus death from what we
know about the death count so far
although the main thing that drives
covet that defines covert 19 deaths his
age
the vast majority of people who die from
covert 19
uh die above the age of 70 and and the
sex rape show from countries where we
can count it reliably
suggests that about uh for every female
uh who dies there's about three males
so we got a fairly clear idea of the age
and sex
composition of mortality are we slowing
down the death rate since we've
been going at this for about 10 months
now have we learned enough to slow it
down
the answer is no we have not slowed it
down i don't know whether we've learned
enough to do that but we certainly
haven't applied it
death rates are rising we're seeing
second waves in several countries in
europe
we've seen those in my country in
australia deaths are rising
uh they're rising steadily and they're
going to rise a lot further
when should we expect the next milestone
say 2 million 3 million do you have a
prediction
it's always difficult to predict but my
prediction is that
by the end of this year by december 31st
we'll probably see at least two million
possibly as high as two and a half
million
cobra 19 deaths worldwide professor are
deaths the best way to understand
the impact of this disease in the
pandemic
i don't think so i think the actual
numbers of deaths as frightening as they
are and as frightening as they're going
to be
don't tell the full story colbot 19
kills people primarily at older ages and
in terms of preventive
priorities that public health need to be
concerned about we talk about the number
of years of life
lost on average from from each death and
in terms of covert 19 most of those who
die died older ages and so they tend to
lose
much less years of life than for example
a comparable number of deaths
road traffic accidents for example kills
1.2 million people
every year vast majority of those are a
lot younger than the covert deaths and
so you could argue
that road traffic accidents ought to be
getting at least as much public health
attention
for prevention as covert cobra19 all
right alan lopez professor
and epidemiologist from the university
of melbourne thank you very much
thank you
well our science correspondent derek
williams has been busy looking into your
questions
about the pandemic over now to derek
many of the social controls put in place
are based on asymptomatic transmission
what evidence is there for such a
phenomenon
do people who are asymptomatic transmit
sauroscope 2 to others and if so
then how infectious are they um this has
been one of those issues that's proven
very difficult to come to grips with in
the course of this pandemic for for a
couple of reasons
first of all because we only really
recently began to detect
asymptomatic people on a wide scale um
second because today's asymptomatic
patient
can turn out to be only pre-symptomatic
and and start showing symptoms tomorrow
and we're pretty sure that
pre-symptomatic carriers
can be highly infectious um third
because the viral load an asymptomatic
patient carries
is is usually very similar to that of
someone
showing symptoms so so what evidence is
there that people who test
positive for covid19 but don't ever
develop
symptoms how likely is it that they can
infect others
a pre-print paper set for publication
soon shows
how tricky it can be to prove but but
the researchers think they did it on a
flight from
italy to south korea carrying nearly 300
passengers who at the time
displayed no covet 19 symptoms before
boarding
all of them were given n95 masks and
most
wore them throughout the flight except
at meal times and when they went to the
bathroom
when the passengers arrived and sold
they were quarantined
straight away for two weeks and all of
them were tested on the first day
and the last day of that quarantine six
people
tested positive for covet 19 that first
day of quarantine
but they never developed symptoms they
were confirmed asymptomatic carriers
but one woman who tested negative on the
first day of quarantine
developed symptoms on day 8 of it she
had sat
a few rows away from an asymptomatic
patient and used
the same bathroom as them because of the
timing and what we know about the
viruses
incubation period the researchers
concluded that she was very likely
infected
by one of the asymptomatic passengers on
board the plane
sounds kind of like a sherlock holmes
mystery doesn't it
um it just goes to show you though how
difficult it is
to acquire and interpret this kind of
evidence
many studies have tried but so far none
of them
has been clear-cut enough really for big
health authorities like the who
or the cdc to take a stand on the issue